all right thanks Matthew I saw do good
okay so it's nice to be the first talk
of the entire workshop because the bar
is pretty low right so this is a joint
work with Aaron shine
Xander Schofield I mean you and Joe and
Hannah Wallach for the majority of the
stuff I'm gonna talk about Aaron shyness
the main contributor who who's also been
taught me all of it the basic magic and
you know I'm uh I'm gonna briefly
mention a full of work in which Xander
is really the driving force for making
some of the inference methods more
scalable and practical all right so
before I started my you know faculty
position I was spending some time at
Microsoft Research this project kind of
started with a conversation with Aaron
shine and Hannah Wallach they're experts
in computational social science it's
really another form of data science you
know what they like to think about is
apply some of the statistical tools and
machine learning techniques to discover
latent structure of human interaction
okay so what does that mean the kind of
question they like to think about is you
know for example you know what are the
main topics people are talking about
okay it could be you know what can what
a you know foreign policy was you know
talking about among countries you know
it was about warfare is it about finance
or it could be you know some software
providers thinking about you what are
the customers talking about what are the
questions they like you think about or
within the company what are the main
majority of interaction happening
between teams so in this kind of
question or you know this kind of
problems people like to think about
there's one common feature we just you
know the data would like to look at
often take the form of counts okay so if
this is usually some form can't data
okay so in terms of texts you can think
of it you know as you know counter words
okay so back of words model is modeling
documents as you know work out vector
which she knows
how many times each word appeared okay
and you can also think about networks
which is about you know pairs of actors
within network and how many times they
talk to each other and you can also talk
about you know a van locks you how many
times you know a pair of ends or a set
of events co-occur at the same time okay
so the high-level goal of this project
we like to think about whether we can
use statistical model for this form of
count data okay while preserving privacy
of the actors you know participating in
this kind of interactions okay and which
generates this kind of data all right so
a very bra family of models that
captured many of their count models you
would like to think about it's called
Bayesian persona factorization model
okay so this name may not be familiar
with the ear but the only in bits you
know some of the you know special cases
you might have heard of okay so you
might have heard of topic modeling or
you know LD as a method of discover
topic models within a text corpus you
might have heard of stochastic block
models which is a way to discover you
know communities within large network
and you know there are other examples
such a population models for you know
genetic data and many others okay so in
this time mostly we'll think about the
first two examples but this is a general
technique ok so let me top into what
Bayesian persona factorization actually
look like okay so you know in the most
general sense you have some observable
countable events okay
usually these kind of collections that
counter statistics is organizing to some
kind of matrices okay
and what you would like to think about
anything else because these are count a
very common way to model counts as a
random variable is think of it being
drawn from some per song distribution
with unknown mean okay so and you know
what we would like to learn is you know
the structure of the mean within this
you know matrix
and we're gonna would like to think
about you know even though this could be
a very large matrix there's some nice
low dimensional lating structure within
the matrix that we would like to
discover so in some sense if I give you
the actual unknown matrix of means you
will be able to factory factorize it
into you know
summary matrixes of low rank okay so let
me give you some concrete examples of
how you should think about some of
examples okay so suppose you're here
you're looking at a social network and
your end-users talking to you know
different set of end users same set of
end users okay so you can think about
number of times any pair of users
interact as you know some kind of count
generated from some kosong you know
distribution okay and what I would like
to understand this you know how are the
user partition into different set of
communities okay so one way to think
about this question is you know we would
like to factorize this large matrix into
basically three matrices two of which
are the same okay so the two long matrix
is basically what we like to call the
user community likelihood okay so you
know given the set of like communities
you know each user basically have
different ways over different
communities okay and you know we're
gonna put the long matrix on two sides
and you know we're gonna multiply it
with the square of small square matrices
of K by K given you know came
communities and this is sometimes called
inter community likelihood okay so a
model how often you know you know actors
are from to communities talk to talk to
each other okay so that you know when
you multiply all those matrices together
that fully specify how end-users talk to
you each other you know oh four okay so
here's another example
you know we like to think about topic
models coming from text corpus okay so
here the matrix is a little different
okay documents by words matrix you can
think about each row of the matrix
correspond to a word count vector okay
so given documental like to specify how
many times each word has appeared in the
document
and again I'm gonna think about you know
the number of times a war appear as you
know drawn from this persona
distribution for with unknown mean and
would like to factorize this you know on
no matrix and do two matrices okay the
third matrix is you know about document
topic parameters okay so given a
document I would like to discover you
know why is the mixture topics that you
know enter into this dr. document okay
and then there's a second matrix which
is about topic word parameters okay so
given a topic I would like to you know
specify why are the likely words that
appear in in this given topic okay so
both of which I assumed to be at low
rank because you know even though there
are many many documents I imagine the
number of topics people like to talk
about it's much lower than the number of
documents ok any questions about
specification yes yeah just not used to
thinking about this wise Poisson
distribution instead we've come it's an
easy way to model you know non-negative
integers and it's only specified by one
parameter and also you can do easy
basing update okay those sort of play
reason why you see you can ask the same
question why Gaussian is used in you
know will value you know yeah it's a
mathematical tractability but at the
same time it seemed to work pretty well
but you know there are cases in which
you might want to make some changes to
the distribution
it's just a question along this line
hopefully interracial allocation there
are actually a binomial right yes so so
poised on is considered a limit when
people super me and number of data
points yes
so does this directly cover out the egg
I can tell I think so yeah for for
special cases aldia but you know there
are so many work on Lda that I wouldn't
just you know blatantly say that a
couple of all cases of Lda all right so
so just to give you some more you know
context you know we've been taking a
Bayesian approach so we're gonna assume
they're scammer priors over these latent
parameters that specify these low-rank
literacies what we would like to do is
you know given Neal a specific basic
model how the latent parameters interact
with each other in the prior and observe
data we would like to form a posterior
over the latent parameters okay so I
would like to learn you know one of the
distributions over the topics for
example or what are you know the
potential communities that you know
underlie the entire social network okay
so you know one example again is the
puppy model case where you know for each
document would like to think about what
are the mixture of topics you know and
each topic is specified by the set of
likelihood the most likely words that
appear in a given topic okay so this is
just a picture of giving you some more
context all right so you know this is a
data science and privacy workshop of
course you know we'd like to think about
you know what happened
what kind of inference technique we
would like to use if the you know
collection and statistics contain
sensitive information okay so you know
specifically what we don't want to
happen is you know once we discovered
the latent structure we don't want the
latent structure that get published to
review too much about a specific
document about a specific interaction
between pairs of actors so this is a
motivation and of course you know the
way we won't like to think about a
formal privacy guarantee is using
differential privacy okay so I'm gonna
do defer the actual formal definition
when you use in this paper to later but
you know for this audience most of us
are experts in this field so you know
the high-level idea is you know we'd
like to introduce randomness in our
computation to ensure that you know the
probability of any outcome remains
approximately the same if any single
observation and data
change in operate arbitrary manner okay
so the actual privacy context we think
about is actually a strong variant of
differential pricing would like to think
about local differential privacy which
is recently deployed in many
organizations so the way you introduce
the randomness into a computation it's
actually introducing into the data
so before you aggregate data I'm gonna
add noise to the collection of
statistics and then I would like to you
know perform my basing inference on top
of the the noisy noisy counts so this is
should not be something you haven't seen
before okay so what kind of noise should
we act okay so it did the thing about
the kind of data we look at here the
kind of data we have here is basically
counts which is non-negative integers
okay so the noise we like to think about
usually it'll applause of Gaussian which
is often wheel value so it's a bit
strange to actually mixing the wheel of
Illinois's with integer counts but you
know this is an easy problem to fix so
you know if you only dealing with the
integers in your data there's actually a
very easy way to perturb the data using
the so called two sided geometric
mechanism or the geometric mechanism
which is generating you know integer
noise that kind of look like a discrete
Laplace distribution and you can perturb
the data using this kind of you know
just the Laplace slide distribution okay
so now the problem is kind of augmented
okay
so now you know before what we look at
is you really we assume that true data
is generated from some person like
leader distribution and would like to
factorize it into some set of you know
low rank with later matrices okay but
now we actually don't get to observe the
true data okay what we observe is we
leave you know the true data added with
two-sided geometric noise okay so what's
good about this setting still is even
though we don't actually observe the
true data we know how
the perturbation take place we know the
noise parameter in some sense which is
you know kind of the privacy parameter
in the Leighton you know privacy
mechanism okay so the new goal here
which is no different from based basic
you know Bayesian inference here is now
suppose your data is being perturbed by
some privacy locally private mechanism
how do you actually form posterior over
the latent parameters okay
question so far
all right so let's revisit this problem
and you know what would what would you
do in this setting okay so you know if
you do think this is you know thinking
about noise add noise perturbing the
data is you know too much work here's
something you you might want to try
Thanks you know in my actual work is so
called naive method what you do is you
know given this noisy data you just
pretend that you know the noise was
never there okay
you have to do a bit extra work because
the distribution is you know two-sided
so you actually have may have negative
counts but you could you know truncate
it back to zero and pretend the noise
was never added and just do you know
standard croissant factorization music
incoherent does that lead term or is it
just like we showed more actual plot
this should not be here okay so the
question you check can we do better than
this naive method okay so you know we're
kind of being ignorant about the noise
we added we should be thought of as part
of the data generative process okay so
what we would like to do is you know we
can think about you know the noise we
add from the geometric mechanism as part
of the you know data generative process
and actually take that into account in
our Bayesian inference okay so in a way
kind of similar to some prior work by
Williamson and McSherry but they were
using this kind of you know posterior
approach improved accuracy okay release
so what we would like to do is you know
we want to take both be no underlying
generative process of the true data into
account along with you know the noising
mechanism for local privacy which we do
know the parameter okay so you know the
question is can we actually do that
because you know seems a little
complicated we basically augmented the
data process with some additional noise
and you know this is it worthwhile to
effort to actually do that okay all
right so so you know let's you know
basically we visit what will you have
done if there's no noise at it
so there's some standard method for
forming posterior given the model and
observe data okay so suppose you're you
know latent parameters really is given
by two matrices theta empty okay so you
know the standard method is called
Markov chain Monte Carlo or MCMC you
know what it does is really construct
some form of Markov chain okay what you
do is you know you initialize the true
parameter theta and feed with you know
some initial value and iteratively you
would do the following gave in the
candidate value of the parameter you
sample the other parameter given by this
can you know complete conditional on you
know the candidate parameter and observe
data and then you alternate between them
you will also do the same thing for the
other parameters so you perform this
alternating update choose to keep
sampling new parameter given by the
conditional distributions okay and what
can you say about this MCMC method if
you run this forever you know there's
some nice math you can do you can show
that you know it will convert you some
stationary distribution which is the
exact posterior of course you know you
never run this forever
so rather you run it long enough from
you know for it via preps to thousand
iterations and take the latch bad last
batch of iterates and use that to
approximate the underlying posterior
distribution the points you know this is
pretty well understood and you know for
without privacy concern this is you know
typically what people do for Bayesian
inference and it works pretty well okay
now we don't actually have the luxury to
directly apply that okay so what we have
here is not just the you know the
underlying later models that generate
the true data rather we also add noise
to the observed data right so the the
actual data we we get as you know the
true data with some you know added some
two-sided geometric noise okay so what
we would like to do is you know actually
condition on the noisy data taking into
account that you know there are you know
the underlying mechanism the generator
is true data and also the randomizing
respond
method the noise a data okay so we want
to do a slightly more complicated
posterior inference so how do you do
that okay so I would like to relate this
you know locally private inference with
something we know how to do very well
which is you know the standard
MCMC method okay so I'm gonna expand
this conditional distribution slightly
by introducing the true data kind of as
a part of the latent variable okay so I
can expand out this conditional
distribution by taking an integral over
the true data okay given the you know
the observed noisy data I can you know
Sam I can form measure over the the true
data Y and you know I can take the
conditional over conditional on the
noisy data over both the latent
parameters and the true data okay so
it's a lot of us to you know basically
think about another form of MCMC if we
introduced the Y as two as part of
making parameters as well okay so what
we can do is you know insert the true
data as pretending it sa face of
parlaying parameters and do this kind of
sampling from this complete conditionals
okay all right so if we are able to
sample the true data given by you know
this conditional distribution the rest
of the sampling inside this Markov chain
update is really the same okay so given
the true data Y what I would like to do
is you know this is just like a
parameter for the latent parameter I'm
gonna sample this the same set of latent
parameters I care about in the same way
as in standard MCMC the challenge here
is you know given a candidate for theta
and Phi and the noisy data how do we
sample from the you know from this
distribution which generate candidates
for the true data
this is a high-level picture make sense
all right so okay so it says now that
we're getting into the harder part with
riches you know it's in hi science the
other thing is a little bit deal magical
so what we're gonna do is steal we
interpret the actual female noising the
noisy mechanism perturbing by you know
the two-sided geometric points so here's
you know how we observe the data okay so
we're given you know count certain count
statistics which we assume is generated
from a certain croissant distribution
with a known mean parameter meal and you
know the privacy mechanism is drawing
some noise variable from the two solid
geometric mechanism or two sides yo
metric distribution and here's the y2
that plus/minus is what we observe so
this is you know kind of the data
generator in the process we face given
the privacy mechanism okay so I'm gonna
do some changes in how we think about
this process okay so here's a useful
fact you know the two-sided geometric
distribution or you know any random
variable generated from it can be
simulated by the following process I'm
gonna you know draw two geometric noise
variable and then just take the
difference of it this is actually
exactly you know the same distribution
as a two sided geometric mechanism in
fact that's how you would implement the
distribution okay so here's a plot for
geometric distribution okay so this is a
slightly different way to rewrite the
distribution all right here's another
useful fact okay so
you know that underlying you'll observe
your true data variable is generated
from the Poisson distribution it'd be
nice if we translate everything into the
person way okay
so actually another way to think about
the geometric distribution is basically
exponentially a randomized per song
random variable okay what do I mean by
that you know you can actually generate
you know random variable lambda from the
exponential distribution with certain
parameter and the geometric random
variable is really just you know Poisson
distribution with with this random
parameter okay so you can actually
rewrite these two you know noise mech
noise you add as some form of persona
random variable as well so let's take
one more set nice property about the per
song distribution is if you take any two
persona in a variable all together and
you add them it's still a persona random
variable with the parameters adding up
as well okay so you can basically
rewrite this process by merging these
two first two terms okay so these are
basically two for some random variables
I'm gonna replace it by a single person
random variable okay now things can get
even simplified because you know now at
the end we really just think of the
observed noisy data as a difference
between two Poisson random variables
which in a way is you know has a name
for it which is called the scale and
distribution and you know religious it's
just you know a name for a difference
between two poisson random variables
with mean specified by the two for some
random variables okay
so all right so what have we done so we
basically you know rewrite an entire
generative process by you know thinking
about the observed data the observed
noisy data as some random variable
generated five by some distribution
called Scallon but directly relating the
random variable to the latent parameters
okay so we're basically somehow
sidestepped you know the observed data
in some sense even though it's weaving
in there when we generate the noisy
noisy counts okay so now we what we
would like to do eventually is you know
given this noisy count and you know
given some candidate of the mute of the
mean of the persona in a variable we
generate the true data okay we generated
you know draw from the posterior of the
true data okay so how do we do that okay
so so keep in mind that you know the MU
DB is still the true mean of the true
data we kind of getting there because
you know what we observe it what the the
noisy counts we observe it actually
government almost by the same random
variable except that you know we
actually perturb it by two random
variable for which we know the exact
distributions okay so for that I'm gonna
go through a small thought experiment
okay so is this is a bit technical but
I'll be over soon okay so suppose I want
to draw to per some random variables
okay I'm gonna define you know to
quantity associated with these two
variables one is that basically the
difference between them okay the other
is you know the minimum between these
you know among these two variables okay
and we know yeah the first one is really
the vessel of the X column distribution
which is what we observed the second one
I also has the name is called Bessel
distribution you don't have to actually
need to know that okay but so this is
one way to generate the set of four
variables at the same time I could
actually directly generate these two
okay by drawing those skeleton
variable first and enjoying a vessel
distribution a vessel random variable
second which will allow me to actually
directly to deterministic way we
construct the tube for some variable in
the first place okay so why would do we
want to do that what we have is
basically some random variable generated
from the skeleton distribution okay and
but the actual variable would like to
draw which is the true data as from this
persona distribution so you know in the
end we would like to generate the sample
from the Poisson distribution using this
kind of deterministic relationship so
why would that be useful so let me visit
the problem we started with so we have
noisy town which can be thought of as
generated from this scale and
distribution okay which is the
difference between two poisson random
variables and we can also define a
minimum between these poisson random
variables you know which is new
something drawn from a Bessel
distribution so by introducing these two
random you know latent variables we can
actually sample from them okay we can't
incorporate them as part of the the MCMC
Markov chain okay what's nice that is
that you know now we can actually
recover something that is the sum of the
the true data count with added with the
poisson latent variable which we we know
the dish where the distribution is from
okay so at the end of that you know one
nice fact we'll use is that you know
suppose we know the sum of two persona
in two variables is you know added up to
some constant what we would like to do
is draw you know one of the you know
Poisson random variable this is really
the same as drawing from the binomial
distribution okay and this can be
officially implementable okay so join
from binomial distribution it's much
easier than sampling from the bessel
distribution okay so that was you know a
long tour you know
across many of the distribution and much
of the base in math but you know at the
end of day what what have we done
so we basically take the two-sided
geometric mechanism we interpreted the
noisy mechanism as part of the data
generator process which allow us to
actually you know derive pretty clean
form of how we can generate this true
cows as part of the latent parameter
okay so this man might look very
complicated at the same time is pretty
promising because all we you know we lie
on is you know the underlying data is
generated from Poisson distribution with
unknown parameters okay so this is a
very my class of models and basically
this this kind of you know basing an
update can actually be applied to all
these models as well okay so this is
quite nice so something I've been waving
my hands on as you know how do we
formulate the the privacy you know
guarantee in this sort setting okay so
one challenge we face for this sort form
of count data is that you know for
example if I'm given a document
represented as workout vector there's
usually no a priori guarantee of how
long how many words the document can
take okay so in some times to provide
your local prize a guarantee it could be
difficult because you know that in some
sense that l1 sensitivity could be very
large okay so we could we're going to
twist the definition a bit instead of
thinking about the indistinguishability
among all possible pairs of observations
we only you know impose it on nearby
observations okay so it's a weaker
guarantee and this kind of you know
relaxation also appear in other domain
you for example you might think about
financial Network where you know this
large transaction money but you know you
don't actually want at noise scaling to
the worst case transaction the amount of
transaction yet and also to location
data recently you know there's you know
the notion profile-based local privacy
which is a you know also a
generalization of this guarantee so in a
in the case of documents what it means
is you you might still learn something
about the entire document but you will
know where does
specific set of words or tokens appear
in the document at all provided that the
number n is covering it's large enough
to cover the size of tokens you want to
protect okay yes I'm trying to think
about the examples you gave it seems
like most of them would do okay with
averaging instead of counting right if
they have a longer document is I saw it
related to more subjects and the same
goes for a person that just uses more
perhaps but you know I'm not doing
averaging here I'm actually doing local
pricing here if someone sent me a worry
factor workout vector I'm gonna directly
noise that there's no averaging effect
among people you could think about you
know maybe you can do better in a small
essential model I mean averaging in the
sense of per person instead of having
dealing with accounts dealing with the
percentage of the words in the document
that were related to a certain subject
or the percentage of his communications
that were with a given person and always
have it sum to one because they have the
in sort of I don't think that
normalization will actually help you
here if you everything is some to want
the noise you had to steal some to one
you still be raising all the information
then you don't have a prop you don't
need to add difference that you've
noticed a different person it's it's
just baked into the fact that some of
them had more communications that were
spread but still so the the noise where
I will be the same and every person you
like you know it should not be the
mechanism should not be depending on the
data so only the guarantee is dependent
and not the mechanism yeah so by you
know in our case actually the mechanism
doesn't even depend on end you know if I
fix a noise wait I took that add to
every you know observe the observation
you know I actually have this guarantee
for any end but the epsilon just get
words for larger okay
your question maybe a right so make them
take my dad check wrong but uh this
looks a bit like sort of event level
award level privacy with very smart like
epsilon setbacks on over n yeah it's
almost our level but no maybe like a set
of token level like right B if I told on
top of it you allow lots of words to
change yeah where lots lots of Monsters
Inc yeah so here's one example that I
came up with last night I suppose
someone send me an email containing
certain contents most of the stuff it's
not sensitive it's like proof that
someone came up with that but but maybe
it's a certain set of key words are more
sensitive okay so what would like to do
this you know maybe I don't actually try
to blind me at large mountain notes to
protect the entire email a document but
you know add noise step so that you know
certain sense of the key words would not
be discovered by it you look Anand okay
so
oh wow okay so gonna just briefly talk
about some of the experiments we did for
the paper so you know one thing I would
like to revisit this you know I talked
about this naive method for basing the
inference given noisy data which is you
know pretended noise was never there but
you have to use some small amount of
pre-processing basically given the noisy
observed data what you can do is you
know look at some of the negative counts
because your add noise that's imbalance
might actually make some accounts
negative you can truncate it back back
to zero okay and that just pretend the
noise was never added and perform you
know posterior update over the noisy
data okay so basically you know you
would like to do better than this your
naive method after all we did a lot more
you know complicated math so the setting
is you know we're gonna you know
actually generate synthetic data okay so
we're gonna generate products process
you know data matrixes for off means for
the Poisson distribution and you know
we're gonna print out data given by this
distribution okay so this is what the
matrices the heat map the matrices look
like we're gonna add you know two-sided
geometric mechanism to the data which
you know we're know as a data quite a
bit and you know some of the counts will
be negative so what you do by you
truncating all the negative counts to
zero and do naive posterior update you
get some you know estimate that look
like this okay so and you know our SMA
you know at least visibly look better at
least we we can't recover the most
concentrating block in the matrix and
and the more importantly actually
produce a more sparse estimate okay so
if we don't actually think about the
noise added deal and you know the knife
posterior has to may actually produce a
much denser estimate
some you know toy example also run you
know to buy a planet to topic modeling
to the State of Union addresses you know
here's one sample topic you know you
just run the standard MCMC method you
know one topic you know will include
keywords such as you know your dollars
billion physical expenditure war
increased total estimated okay and if
you applied the naive method
you also get similar topic actually you
know for prefix of them actually look
pretty pretty reasonable but later on
you as you go down the list of the
keywords in this topic you know there's
some some words that you know by
eyeballing and you realize this should
not be their first place and and our
method you know seems to be better in
terms of recovering this kind of topic
model basically we recover the kind of
keywords that should appear when you're
talking about you know spending of the
government different things okay so so
we also perform experiments on other
real data set there's this data set
called Imran data set which is quite
nice for our purposes because you know
it covers both the text data case which
is you know you know they give natural
text about email content and also a
model is how you know a second actors
interact with each other eventually they
also give a network data set so one
thing we did is you know we take the
data and we would like to use our
Bayesian estimate to provide a point
estimate for all the mean parameters and
we would like to calculate the mean
absolute error in recovering these
little mean parameters and our method
actually do better almost matching the
non-private case and much better than
the knife case because the knife case
actually often produce much dancer
estimates so you know many parameters
should have been 0 in the first place
the naive method we actually fear
zero value and there's also a measure of
coherence in terms of the topics I'm not
gonna go in here but you know higher
value of careers means better
so we also you know we're beating the
the nice method as well okay so we also
use the same data set for community
detection the problem of community
detection so so you know the same and
one data said your model roughly a set
of you know people emailing each other
and the private data there is kind of in
some sense H privacy would like to
protect how many times me and Mark have
talked over the last year up to some
position so what was surprising thing we
realize is you know this is we're data
set so you know it probably did how
given out how the world works the data
may not actually be generated from a
person you know so all random variable
and you know our method our proposed
method actually beat the non private
method in some sense so this is some
surprising effect of you know actually
telling the MCMC algorithm that we are
adding noise to the counts and
performing inference over them one thing
we do observe you know by telling the
MCMC algorithm we add noise and you're
taking the true data as a part of the
latent parameter into the inference our
method actually produce much sparser
estimate of the later main parameters
somehow this actually helped you know
the improve the accuracy because most of
the you know data would deal with are
very sparse okay so if you're given a
word dog workout document most of the
words would not appear in the stocking
so most of our entries are 0 so sparse
are they actually helping for the
accuracy sorry the non-private version
is still the Bayesian method but just
you don't have to worry
yeah oh well there's no noise added
right it's no noise out but it's still
exactly the same Bayesian model yes
did you try running your technique on
the nonoise data yes that would be a
good thing to try it could be that you
know we could lie about you know light
light to the MC MCL with and that would
pretend we had a noise probably there is
noise and it's sort of acknowledging
that that's right so so when we're kind
of in a pipe IX investigating that and
you know maybe we'd like to your
previous question you know why is the
you know true callus generated the
Poisson distribution probably not but
it's a four nicely saying mathematical
tractability we use that but you know
somehow by telling the algorithm there's
noise it helped to overcome some of the
overfitting of you know the Poisson
distribution
so I'm not showing here I think if you
if your synthetic data it's actually
generated from this like for song
distribution the non private method
would do better in our experiments like
if everything is like generated from the
ground truth distribution we know the
latent parameters just by adding noise
which should not improve your accuracy
but this is like data just like real
data that we try to fit like the Poisson
matrix model over have you tried at all
smaller values of epsilon over N because
I mean this is not that restaurant
privacy so how bad it does it break down
good question I don't remember I can
take it up with like a larger experiment
it just be it would deter over time
or as you increase you if I understand
correctly you're decreasing in epsilon
as you go so so you should think of it
as we just you know changing the amount
of noise we add which will get which
directions of more noise good question
it looks like it's going to the lake to
the right is more noise then going to
this direction is less noise
nice Princeton I think we have an
explanation in paper let me think about
I guess my question really was does the
red line ever go back up or is it just
like thanks all house it could be you
know you actually push it that at some
point push to the dollars and produce
sparsit's and as far as estimate at some
point you know if you're overly sparse
it should go back up presumably so
here's a possible explanation of what's
happening so so buy it buy it buy you
creep by increasing with the amount of
noise and your eyes actually tell me our
algorithms out I'm adding more noise it
is integrating out the kind of noise by
introducing some kind of a
regularization yeah so that was the idea
those are the spice of the idea so that
you could be over these spies over time
so it could be the like maybe answer an
atom question if you push the regime
larger that it could be go back up like
yeah yeah
adding more noise is giving you less you
don't wanna crazy and what I was asking
increasing the amount of NIH's do you
see something better
my question is not in the extremities
you have for the accuracy as well
because this is just a simulation
experiment right so I see some bar there
is that just the feature of the plotter
is that really an iPad version
confidence interval for B so this is
like enjoying from the posterior so we
don't have no confidence in Turbo Power
I think we have like maybe there's a lot
of overlap between the green line and
the red line if you actually look at the
posterior confidence intervals rather
than via the point estimate of the mean
good idea actually
you know one thing what you do is take
the last batch of rates and see how big
a variation is
rushon
we are under second in the experiment
so we don't actually need to commit to
and one nice consequence of using the
geometric mechanism is you know you just
need to fix the noise rate for every
possible ballot and you get a fix value
epsilon so you can't reinterpret you
know the prize the guarantee for
different so we take the proof so
another thing I would like to mention
the end you know you know one one thing
you know that maybe it's less satisfying
about this work is we actually add noise
to the entire cow matrix okay so so the
original data might actually be
extremely sparse as I mentioned but now
actually basically a dance matrix with
almost every entry being nonzero so you
know the algorithm actually is much
slower compared to the non private out
with them where you you're doing with
sparse data so you don't actually
explicitly need to write down the entire
matrix so we have been doing some
ongoing work for doing faster inference
instead of doing the private MCMC method
you know we're trying to incorporate you
know the basing characterization of the
posterior to actually do a variational
inference so which is the kind of
approximation you know come out with
them for forming the posterior you
specify a model to approximate posterior
and you optimize over parameters and you
know we have some pretty interesting a
nice improvement over the run time right
that's it thank you
so in the experiments the data is
collected would pretend is distributed
but you can think about it as you know
in a company situation where you know
maybe there's some manager collecting
the data but before the data is
collected the employee actually noise
accounts so everything is knowing so you
can't directly I have back to one
question yes
so you said did you get to certain women
to variational methods but this is
you're already doing a Gibbs sampler
with conjugates and my understanding is
like the updates probably gonna be done
almost imperil l when it comes time to
do the now thanks so that it's gotta be
amazingly fast already like I would have
thought No
so there have some details I'm hiding
for example sampling from a vessel
distribution actually is very slow even
though you do the parallelization
actually doing the introducing all the
latency layer and later and variable and
standpoint phrase it's non-trivial so
then is it where you kind of if you just
support the Travis I'm a droplets update
where you don't worry about trying to do
a conjugate
I mean you said I would assume you are
still big faster than this though
you mean the knife method or no no no so
what I mean is that what you did is you
basically work out the conjugate
distribution right yeah so you can do
the Gibbs updates however you've never
had to do that you could have just done
metropolis which basically says the
posterior is proportional yes that's
true